Relations in the United States today.
Marvelously complicated question.
Um,
there was an article in the Washington
Post today about some of Obama's workers
being
disturbed or more than disturb,
horrified by some of the racial
responses they'd had when they go ask
people to vote for Obama.
So race in America is certainly better
than it's ever been.
I don't believe that racism of unsorted
or another is curable.
I think it's always something that's
there for people who need it to use it.
Um,
whether it's racism,
antisemitism,
Annika,
fallacy ism and a immigration.
There are people for whom that will
always give them some kind of
sustenance.
And,
um,
I think part of the problem is that we
think we can do away with that and we
can,
and I think also the part of the problem
is that we ask ourselves to cure
ourselves.
I don't think,
I think that there are still elements of
racism and anyone,
anyone,
no matter how much they believe they've
overcome it,
it's still there.
And to make,
to try to kid yourself and think that
it's not is makes it harder.
I think it's important to recognize that
human beings tend to think in a,
in a binomial way.
We think yes or no.
We think good or bad.
We think black or white,
and that's in our minds,
that's the structure of our minds and we
can,
we have to struggle against it,
but we can't pretend that it's not
there.
And I think sometimes we ask people to
get to shed that from themselves to,
to,
to free them from it and people can't.
It's there.
It's part of our mental structure and I
think it's very crucial that people
recognize no it,
that other people have,
that
it's the way our minds are constructed,
our mindset.
It may have to do with something like
computers who the on off through our
electrons work the same way in our
brain.
They're either clicking on or clicking
off and we tent.
That's the way we work.
We think the first thing we think is a,
uh,
is a yes or no answer,
a two sided answer.
And then we learned that in fact there
are many two sided answers in the middle
of those things,
that it isn't black or white,
that there are graze.
It isn't good or bad.
There are things in the middle that
temper that,
but as long as we pretend that we can
overcome that,
I think it causes us more green.
So long concert,
I thought that question,
how does one identify?
So I think primarily the primary
identity is that we're members of the
same species and that that that's
absolutely crucial to us that our future
depends on our realization that we're
part of the same species and that
everything else is subservient to that.
As long as we think of ourselves
primarily as American or French or or
whatever Iraqi,
we're going to continue to divide and
continued to find conflict.
And I think that the,
the,
the hope is the great,
I've been reading a lot about
globalization,
not just globalization as commerce,
but global globalization as concept of
the way human beings had been
globalizing ever since history began.
Before history,
we came out of Africa and spread over
the world.
That was the first globalization.
And I think that the,
the,
the kind of globalization we have now
where there's communication,
did intimate communication between
everybody in the world might be what's
going to save us from our batteries.
Okay.